thanks to surf shark for sponsoring this
video find out more later on hey 42 here
in 2002 52 year old karen keegan lay in
her hospital bed in boston massachusetts
awaiting a kidney transplant she was
suffering from acute kidney failure but
the search for a compatible organ donor
had been so far unsuccessful
concern for the ailing mother her three
adult sons underwent genetic testing to
see whether any of them could spare a
compatible kidney
but
when the tests had been processed
the doctors were met with some
surprising results
two of karen's sons weren't actually
hers
now if karen had been male the
implications of this test would have
been obvious plenty of men have
discovered later in life that they
didn't really father their children
but karen was not male and that made
absolutely no sense whatsoever after all
she knew the boys were hers on account
of you know having given birth to them
the genetic tests revealed that she was
thankfully related to her sons she was
their biological aunt
and
yet
karen had no sisters
so what the hell was going on
now if you love travelling then you'll
love the fastest and easiest vpn surf
shark did you know surf shock also helps
you to avoid price discrimination based
on your location so you can actually
save money on plane tickets and car
rentals whilst travelling
surfshark runs on any device anywhere
and it's packed full of features such as
industry-leading uncrackable encryption
ip and dns leak protection an internet
kill switch if your vpn drops out and 24
7 customer support by using surfsharkvpn
you can stay anonymous and secure online
but personally i use surfshark to watch
netflix content from other countries
such as the us that's usually blocked
here in the uk it's really easy all you
have to do is switch over your location
settings and there you have it you've
got access to all your favorite programs
surfshark maintains a strict no logs
policy and their network of 3
200 servers in over 65 countries runs
completely on ram so they couldn't like
your data even if they wanted to by
using the code 42 you will benefit from
an 83 discount plus four extra months
for free during the holiday period the
1st of november to the 31st of december
all you have to do is click the special
link in the description below don't miss
out a few months later lydia fairchild
received a similar test result claiming
that she was not the biological mother
of her two children she was accused of
fraud and nearly lost custody
but luckily for lydia her attorney
stumbled across the story of karen
keegan in the nick of time
you see both karen and lydia had
something in common
they both had a secret twin and i don't
mean a long-lost twin like luke
skywalker and princess leia
i mean a secret twin that was hidden
inside of them
confused
they were too but as it turns out not
only were their bodies made up of their
own cells containing their own dna
they also played host to the cells of
their unborn twin sisters which
contained a second totally unique
genetic code
some of the egg producing cells in their
ovaries must have contains this second
genome from their lost twins
meaning that both lydia and karen had
given birth to the children of women who
had never been born
this incredibly weird phenomenon is
known as biological chimerism it's named
after the chimera a fire-breathing beast
from greek mythology
with the body and head of a lion a
protruding goat's head on its back and a
serpent at the end of its tail
human chimeras are a little less
dramatic than that but they do have some
distinguishable features
some have two-tone skin or different
colored eyes
two different blood types or if the twin
cells are of a different sex
both male and female genitals
but most human chimeras don't show any
noticeable signs of the condition at all
karen's chimerism hasn't even showed up
in her blood tests because her blood
cells were all produced from a single
cell line her own
so why does this biological chimerism
occur well early in a twin pregnancy the
embryos are in close enough contact that
one twin can absorb the cells of the
other in the case of human chimeras one
twin fully absorbs the cells of the
other fusing their embryos together to
produce one individual with two
different genomes
just like karen and lydia
embryonic cell absorption isn't the only
way biological chimeras can form either
in fact if you've ever had an organ
transplant or a blood transfusion
you too will be carrying around another
human's dna inside your body this can be
quite problematic in forensics because
there's a small chance that an
individual's genetic fingerprint
might not actually be theirs
for example in 2004 dna collected from a
sexual assault case was matched to that
of a man who had been behind bars at the
time of the attack
a rerun of the blood tests confirmed it
was definitely his dna but how could he
have committed the crime from his high
security cell
harry potter style time turner's aside
one person just can't be in two places
at once
or can they well no
not without
amputations
but your dna can be
you see a few years earlier this man had
received a bone marrow transplant from
his brother
bone marrow is the soft tissue that
fills the cavity in the center of our
bones and it's responsible for
maintaining a constant supply of healthy
blood cells to the body including more
than 220 billion new red blood cells
every single day as a result the man's
blood contained his brother's dna as
well as his own and it was his brother's
dna not his that had been found at the
scene of the crime
but you don't need something as dramatic
as an organ transplant to end up with
other people's dna in your cells
during pregnancy cells are transferred
between mother and fetus across the
placenta as a result both mother and
baby become
microchimeras
meaning they each carry a small number
of cells with a different genome to
their own the fetus's cells circulate
through the mother's body and can end up
lodging themselves in various organs in
most cases these cells are removed by
the mother's immune system after the
baby's born but some fetal cells stick
around for years
in fact in one study nearly two-thirds
of women had traces of their son's fetal
dna in multiple regions of their brains
decades
after they'd given birth
these same cells can also end up being
transferred to any future fetuses
so if you have older brothers or sisters
you may well have some of their dna
floating around inside of you probably
not enough to frame them for murder
before you start getting any ideas
the thing about these fetal cells is
that unlike most adult cells their fates
haven't yet been sealed under the right
condition these so-called stem cells can
differentiate into almost
any cell type
be that a brain cell a heart cell a
blood cell
you get the idea
once they become lodged in a specific
tissue they use chemical cues from their
neighboring cells to figure out where
they are so that they can develop into
the right cell type for that specific
tissue basically they take trying hard
to fit in to a whole new level
in some cases these fetal stem cells can
actually be beneficial to the mother's
health they've been found in the healed
scars of c-sections
which suggest they may play some role in
wound healing in the mother's body and
in one extreme example a woman's failing
liver suddenly began to regenerate
itself thanks to the lingering stem
cells of a child she'd given birth to
nearly 20 years before
unfortunately these fetal stem cells are
a bit of a mixed blessing
much like most children and have been
associated with increased rates of
autoimmune disease and cancer okay but
what if you have no secret twin no organ
transplants and you've never been
pregnant
surely then all the cells in your body
are just yours
right
actually
no
as weed as this may sound
most of the cells in your body
aren't yours
in fact only about 43 percent are even
human the other 57 of your cells
are the microbes including bacteria and
fungi
that collectively make up your
microbiome
think about that for a second you are
literally a walking pile of fungus
you're welcome
but before you go and ask your gp for a
year's supply of his finest antibiotics
it's worth remembering that without this
army of microscopic interlopers
you literally wouldn't survive
and whilst they may outnumber you at
least these little critters that have
made you their big squishy home aren't
that much of a burden
they only make up around one to three
percent of your total body weight
despite being found pretty much
everywhere on your skin in your mouth in
your lungs and eyes
of course the motherload of microbes are
found in our guts your gut microbes help
you break down food and provide
essential nutrients that your own cells
just can't produce by themselves they
help to stimulate your immune system
when your body is under threat and they
can protect you against infections the
presence or absence of certain microbes
in our guts has also been linked to
countless diseases including diabetes
autism parkinson's disease and obesity
but perhaps one of the most surprising
things about our belly biting bacteria
is their influence in our brain and our
mood
for example mice that have been fed gut
bacteria from people suffering with
depression begin to show signs of
depression themselves
that's because gut bacteria produce
various neurotransmitters like serotonin
and dopamine that play an important role
in regulating our mood
and there's evidence that these microbes
can alter our behavior as well people
with more diverse microbiomes tend to
have larger social networks and shy mice
begin to act more confident when they're
given the gut microbes of their more
adventurous counterparts
it works the other way around too lower
microbiome diversity is associated with
anxiety and stress
being a researcher in this field isn't
exactly the most pleasant of jobs by the
way after all when it comes down to it
it's basically just shifting through
but all that tossing has at least
borne some fruit fecal transplants are
already being used in some hospitals to
repopulate the depleted microbiomes of
patients with serious abdominal ailments
seriously though don't try this one at
home
the human genome is made up of about 20
000 genes
but if you add up all the genes in your
microbiome the figure comes out to
somewhere between 2 and 20 million
your microbiome is also totally unique
to you and even identical twins share
only about 30 of their gut microbes
most of us are first exposed to these
microbes when we pass through our
mother's birth canal but one in five
babies are delivered by c-section which
means that many children miss out on
this important bacterial baptism
but don't worry if you don't happen to
have arrived in this world by being
squeezed out of your mother's vagina
that doesn't mean you'll be cursed with
unhealthy gut microbes for the rest of
your life our environments and our diets
also play a huge role in determining
i've got microbes as does our dna
we used to think of ourselves as being
half mom half dad and a hundred percent
us
but clearly that's not the case
our brains and bodies are constantly
being influenced by the thousands of
other genomes that exist inside of us
and our intimate relationships with
these different cells
are what makes us who we are you aren't
a single entity but a complex ecosystem
one that becomes a little bit more human
statistically speaking
every time you take a dump although
perhaps it's time to redefine what it
means to be human in the first place
thanks for watching
good news you can now pre-order my new
book bread and circuses what did the
romans ever do for us
it's a wild and witty journey for a
thousand years of unexpected roman
history
told in a refreshing way and packed full
of incredible and unbelievable stories
copies are selling out fast so pre-order
yours today to lock it in thank you